Awesome.
Hello everybody. hello, how are we doing? How are we doing?
Everybody had lunch,
good lunch.
All right, awesome. Well, my name is Matt Gibbets
and I'm the principal solutions engineer with Dyna Trace,
and I'm lucky to be joined by one of my esteemed colleagues,
Shannon, as well as one of our esteemed colleagues
from AWS Raj.
What we will be talking about today
is the automated cloud security remediation
with um agentic workflows.
Pretty loaded title, right?
Anybody has any idea what we'll be talking
about? It's,
it's definitely going to be AI. I mean, we have to talk about
AI to stay relevant, right?
And we'll be talking about automation.
So with that said,
let's actually take a look at the agenda.
Looking at the agenda,
we definitely want to highlight and start with the partnership
between Dynaches and AWS because it has been
amazing over the years.
We will then dive in into today's cloud
security challenges,
and lastly, we'll then talk specifically
about security mediation with agentic
workflows.
Now, we do have some Q&A at the end. I'm
more than happy to take it if we have time during the session, but
if we don't, we will stick after, or you can
meet us at the Dina Tre's booth, which is booth 575.
Well, let's just dive in.
We have to start highlighting the key,
essentially highlights of this session. The first one
that we will be talking about is the integration
of DynaTrace
with the AWS security hub.
If you guys are familiar with DynaTrece, obviously DynaTrace
is an observability platform, so we already
provide a lot of value to our customers,
understanding how your application workloads are performing, how
your cloud native services are performing,
whether you have any vulnerabilities in your environment.
But obviously you're all here.
Because you guys are AWS customers, that means
that a lot of your workloads run
in AWS.
So what happens when
there's a vulnerability in one of your AWS
Cloud native services?
Maybe some ports are open in one of your EC2
instances that shouldn't be open.
Now that integration between the AWS
Security hub and
Dynatrace will allow you to have all of your performance
and security data in the same observability
platform.
Once that data is in the same observability
platform, This is now where the AI
enters the stage.
You will be able to use Davis co-pilot
to actually understand and trigger
automation
for any detected security vulnerabilities
and bottlenecks in your AWS environment.
And how is it going to be done?
This is where MCP comes into the stage.
That integration and that igentic
workflow is driven
through an MCP protocol in here.
So with that said,
before we dive into the actual meat and potatoes of how
that um automation will happen, we
have to talk a little bit more about Dynatrace.
This is a slide that I love that word, one
of my favorite words out there,
the architecture slide,
because it shows you a little bit of the architecture of
the Dyna Trece platform,
but it's not deep enough, so, you know, it, it
overlaps with the marketing.
But really what I want you guys to get out of this slide
is
Dyna Chase is an observability platform.
That allows you to understand all of your observability
data in context of each other,
to proactively let you know when there are
issues in your environment,
perform root cause analysis for you automatically,
and then trigger those automation remediation
actions, whether it is remediating
security vulnerabilities
or whether it is actually remediating security bottlenecks.
Since I mentioned that this is the architecture slide,
I know there's probably somebody in here that's, who's wondering
how this is really happening.
So my next slide
lets you guys a little bit under the hood.
How is this really possible that Dynaches is able
to touch the performance data, the security data,
the business data, marry all that in
context, and at the end of the day actually
drive automation.
The key answer to that is grail.
The architecture of the Dyna Tree's platform
is the difference
from many other vendors that you will see on this floor
when it comes to observability.
We created our own back end of
our platform
called Grail.
What Gray allow, allows us to do, it allows
us to store all of that telemetry that
we capture from your environment, whether it's coming from AWS,
whether it's coming from an application workloads, whether
it's coming from logs, whether it's coming from AWS
security hub,
and have all that data in context
of each other.
Once we have all that data and context of each other,
this is where we're not a points tool anymore.
You don't need to have multiple different tools to really
tell you what's happening in your environment.
You have Dyna Chase as your one-stop
shop to understand everything about
your environment and fulfill all of your
observability needs,
whether it has something to do with performance or
with security, how we'll be able to talk about
today. Now, having all the data and context,
being able to analyze it,
this is now
when the key component comes into place, which is automation.
Automation is, is almost a buzzword,
right? Like everybody wants to automate
everything, but if you have incorrect data,
if you have data that doesn't really tell
you the full story of your environment, you will start
automating mistakes.
This is what Dynatree stops you from doing,
because having all that data in context, we'll
be able to really understand what's happening in your
environment at all times and drove, drive
the remediation actions that are accurate
based on the telemetry that we are capturing from your
environment, whether it is from application workloads,
infrastructure, logs,
or like in this case, AWS security
hub.
So with that said, I'll pass it to my colleague from AWS
to talk a little bit more about the partnership between Dynatrace
and AWS.
Thanks a lot, Matt. Uh,
so, before we continue with the presentation, I
would like to talk a bit about
The partnership between DTS and AWS.
DyneTS is an advanced technology partner,
uh, with competencies in, uh,
AI, journey AI,
machine learning, modernization, and migration.
Uh, both Danetrace and AWS have at least about 10+
years of partnership with about
100+ AWS service integrations.
And, uh,
today, the key differentiator between
what we have with DTS and AWS is
AI powered automation and advanced
observability.
So this is what we are going to do a soil
demo after this presentation.
But I just want to highlight that we have like
already 100+ native AWS services
and we have these active integrations in production today.
Let me now introduce you to AWS
Security Hub,
our unified cloud security
solution. So what security hub
does, it's like, it's an
environment or a platform where you can ingest
like vulnerabilities,
threats, security controls,
network exposures,
sensitive data,
and once you collect. This data,
they are
on the back correlated so that you
know which one to pick up, which is like of
maximum importance to you, which you need
to address immediately.
And it also has some actionable insights.
It gives you like a workflow
that tells you like, OK, this is something happening
with the environment,
and these are some of the workflows available for you.
These are some of the remedies available for you.
And you can also have integrations with
various different applications like
Jira or Slack or ServiceNow.
So all these integrations are already available for you.
So when there is an event or any issue
happening with your environment,
Security hub will create all those alerts and all
those remedations automatically for you.
Finally,
the prioritization, right? This is very important. Like
if you're getting hundreds and thousands of
incidents happening, right, it's very hard
for you to pick out which is the right one. So the
prioritization will help you to look into the
top priority one so that you know which is
affecting your business right now.
And
monitoring the security trends, so it's
continuously monitoring your environment against
like AWS inspector,
Amazon guard duty. So all these
are available in a single dashboard for you.
And finally, you can respond at scale.
So like if you have like thousands and thousands of
virtual machines working and you have
all this exposures coming in into
security hub,
it can respond at scale also.
And uh what are the key benefits
of AWS security hub, right? It
prioritize, as I said, it prioritize your
critical security issues so
that you can only look into the top priority
one and
ensure that it has been addressed properly.
It detects core inlets and
then it also has integrations with
various, as I mentioned, like Jira,
ServiceNow,
all those Slack systems so that the
operations teams or the DevOps teams can actually
go and look into it.
And the main advantage of security hub
rather than going into individual dashboards
like. Inspector, you can
have security hub as just one
console where you can have all the
top 10 trends or top highlights happening in
just one console so that you can just concentrate
on the main security hub console rather
than going into all the other
applications or other services.
So before we get into Dimbo, I
will hand it over to Sharon.
Talk about how we are getting all this data from
security hub,
then ingest them into Dina trace
and then work on the remediations, all those things.
Sharon, awesome, thank you so much, Raj.
So who in here is a cloud, uh,
security practitioner? Is anybody a security practitioner?
OK, my friends, my friends, my friends,
um, so are any of you guys doing manual
processes to remediate configuration issues now?
Yes, yes, yes, yes,
OK, so this slide will really resonate
with you, right? So today's security cloud challenges,
um, having a ton of alerts and alert overload
is huge, right? All of us have all this
information flooded and we're not really sure
how to prioritize it, right? So this is where AI and
AI workloads are critical now,
uh, manual processing. These are still in place uh
that are creating bottlenecks and errors across your
teams, um, and again this is just one of
the, the many challenges you're seeing now and
then having these fragmented workflows that are slowing
your response time to critical configuration
issues and, uh, are creating critical gaps
in prioritization and actually your overall
security posture coverage,
um. So this is where
AWS and DynaTrace can help you out.
So using AWS Security Hub to
prioritize and understand those critical
security posture issues, we're able to port those
into DynaTrace using EventBridge and Lambda,
uh, and then using Open Pipeline, which is a DynaTrace
feature. We're able to contextualize all of
those, uh, security alerts and understand.
Their effect against production applications,
right? So how important is this actual security
alert for me to fix?
Very important.
And then, as Matt mentioned, storing it in grail, right?
So that's how we're able to contextualize it with the rest of
the business.
And then DynaTrace allows you to visualize,
analyze, and of course auto remediate, right,
which is the whole purpose of today's
flow. So let's talk a little
bit about what this architecture could look like.
Um, so as we're ingesting these security hub
events, uh, into DynaTrace using OCSF
format, um, we can actually run a workflow
to help you prioritize and
understand the impact of those issues against
your production applications.
Uh, so that workflow will create that Jira ticket,
um, that will basically roll up all of those high
priority issues. For one,
agent to action on and then using
Dynatrace MCP server and Quiro
CLI
we're able to actually apply those fixes
automatically,
right? So think about an agent running, uh, you know,
natural language to remediate these issues automatically
and then having those issues
closed in AWS security hub and then
ultimately closed in DynaTrace.
So let's take a look at this live.
So what you'll see here is we're an AWS security hub
and we're, we see a couple of critical issues here, right?
Related to um an EC2 instance.
So we're gonna go into DynaTrace and find
the security hub integration on our hub,
and you'll see all these really great out of the box dashboards,
right? So kind of plug and play with us.
Once you log in here, you'll see those two issues
and. These particular issues are actually a
EC-2 port that's open, right?
So not something we want to have an EC-2 open to the
internet. This workflow is running, contextualizing
this issue,
understanding the production impact,
and mirroring it in one Jira ticket
with all of your high priority items.
So this is happening automatically in the background.
No need for human intervention.
We can go into Jira and see, um, that
particular, uh, uh, critical issue that we
were looking at, along with all the other high priority
issues that we need to action on.
So let's go ahead and auto remediate using QA.
So we're going to pull up that same JIRA ticket that was automatically
created, pull up those high criticality
findings. And again, your agent is doing
this, not you.
We're going to say, hey, can you verify that this is still an
issue? And that's what's happening here. We're saying,
OK, is that port still open on that EC2?
The answer is yes. So we need to go ahead and fix
it, right?
So from here, we're gonna see what it's uh
affecting in Dynatrace against your production
app. So how critical
is this security issue to the business?
And I can see here all the different applications it's
impacting and everything. And again, an agent is running this
completely autonomously.
And then basically all I did was apply the fix.
I said, go ahead and patch this, close these ports,
and it's completed in 1 2nd.
The last thing we're going to do is verify that our
fix has taken place and the
security issue is no longer a problem.
And what we'll see here is green.
Green is good. Green means yes,
we no longer have this security issue.
And then we're going to verify now that this is automatically
closed in DynaTrace.
So again, we went basically like completely autonomously
from prioritizing the issue,
understanding the impact to completely auto remediating.
So what we're going to do now is go back to security hub
and just as a human,
verify that these issues are no longer a problem.
I can see we went from 7 to 5 critical
issues
and that the 2 that we, we had an issue with
are now automatically resolved. Pretty great,
right? And then we'll
go over to Dina Trace
and make sure that those issues are also no longer
an issue.
And again, totally dropped off our
security issue. So an agent
completely autonomously did that for you, right,
which is really cool.
Um,
so what does this mean? In 2 minutes,
we went from understanding the issues, prioritizing
them, understanding the production and business
impact to auto remediating them using,
uh, like, basically agentic AI,
right? So that gets you speed, uh,
and time to value.
This also gets you efficiency, right, which is reduction
in those configuration errors, uh, basically
by marrying. That with the Dyna trace observability
data
and as our systems, thirdly, as
our systems continue to scale and get more
complex in the cloud, um, and with
AI systems, every business needs
a workflow like this in order to
speed up
their time to value, right, which ultimately
leads us to your acceleration of security
posture management within your organization.
So if this demo resonated
with you,
um, please go ahead and scan our QR
codes here to check out the integration on the hub. Yes,
I see a few of you scanning. Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
And then on the right, if you want to check out observability
with AWS,
go ahead and do that.
I'll leave it up for a little bit longer for our friends.
Awesome. And let me ask one more question. Who could
use this workflow to resolve their issues?
Everybody,
right? Literally everyone,
uh, so if you want to see this live and in action,
please stop by booth 575. We'd be happy to
talk with you and thank you guys so much for your time today.
Cheers.